striking and majestic
the french alps are an enchanting site
for thousands of years people have lived
and worked in the mountains
or simply come to admire them but
scientists warn these ancient peaks
are crumbling rising temperatures are
melting permafrost
the frozen soil and ice that holds them
together
speeding up erosion and triggering
dangerous rock falls
glaciologist flores magna says the high
vertical rock faces of the alps
are particularly vulnerable to changes
in temperature
we have noticed that in warm periods
particularly the last two or three
decades
rockfalls have been more frequent than
in past colder decades
also when the summers are very hot as
they were in 2003
and 2015 the rock falls happened more
often
glaciers are also melting faster than
before
there are 4 000 in the alps chain that
spans seven countries
scientists say half will have
disappeared by 2050.
climate change is also transforming low
altitude mountains
like those in the voge region in eastern
france
it still snows here every winter in
ventron the problem
is the snowfall has become less reliable
the ski season much shorter so that's
why the operator this year
has decided to close the resort thibault
leduc's grandfather created this ski
resort
his family have always run it his aunt
competed in the olympics
shutting the resort down wasn't an easy
decision but he says he had no choice
he now plans to build a luxury hotel to
attract tourists
all year round all the ski stations face
the same problem because to work you
need snow at the right time during the
holidays and good weather
so it's hard to have all that in a short
season we used to have a bad winter
every decade
now it's every three years so it's
impossible to recover
rising temperatures have forced dozens
of ski resorts to close in france in
recent years
scientists warned that unless more is
done to stop climate change
snow-capped mountains and glistening
glaciers may one day
become things of the past natasha butler
al jazeera
ventron livorge well let's speak to
chandra bhushan he's the executive
director of iforest the
international forum for environment
sustainability and technology and he
joins us now
from new delhi chandra we've just been
watching there a report about how
climate change is affecting
one of the richest countries on the
planet and i know you're contending with
widespread impacts there in india
too i mean for so long negotiations
around carbon cuts were about
common but differentiated
responsibilities the rich and poor
divide about
who should do what do you think we're
beyond that now
i think we are beyond that because we
are running short of time
as your report shows and as most of the
scientific report that has come out
in the last few months you know one of
the one of the
uh interesting thing that happens in
climate change is before
december you get to see a lot of updated
report on what is happening across the
world
and we now have report from birth
meteorological organization
unh and everyone is saying that we are
hurtling towards
a climate catastrophe because the
challenges are increasing the impacts
are increasing
whereas the efforts that countries are
putting in in terms of reducing
emissions as well as
adapting to climate change is really
falling short
so yes i i mean to say we now have to
think about a global cooperative
mechanism
there will still be difference between
developed and developing countries in
terms of who can do what because
after all developing countries have less
capacity
but that that division that has actually
made negotiations very difficult
and ambition uh difficult to uh
increase the ambition we will now have
to get past it and start talking about
how do we help each other how do we
build a
global cooperative mechanism to to get
the work done
after all you know uh it is about lives
of people
that we are talking about you mentioned
some of the forecasts there i see
climate tracker now has the planet on
course for
a 2.1 degree rise by 2100 and i know
you personally estimate that it being
closer to 3.2 degrees given
the current investments in fossil fuels
i mean these are hugely devastating
scenarios can you paint a picture for us
as to what that would look like
listen a number of countries have given
mid-century targets saying that they are
going to become net zero emission
by 2050. now number of researchers are
projecting
2.1 degree and 2.2 degree based on 2050
target
but we all understand political cycles
and
while it is important to give a 2050
target and every country
is encouraged to do that it is much more
important to give
five-year target so that we can measure
it we can verify it we can see whether
countries are taking action or not
and therefore i think this message that
is going out is that we are on track to
2.1
actually is quite damaging i think we
will have to
give this message with a lot of
disclaimers the fact is
the current targets that countries have
put on the table
is for 3.2 c now just to i just wanted
to clarify this point
but to paint the picture the fact is 3.2
degrees is
is is unheard of i i'm it's very
difficult for
a scientist to actually project a world
how it is going to impact
people at 3.2 degrees because even
models
uh i mean to say we can give you a
broader picture
of what is going to happen but at the
end of the day there are communities who
are going to be devastated
at 3.2 degrees you're talking about alps
in india
we have sundarbans which is going to be
devastated we have
alpine meadows we have grasslands we
have such
you know vulnerable ecosystems and
communities dependent on the
those ecosystems they are going to be
devastated at even 1.5 degrees 3.2
degrees
so we are as i started by saying we are
dealing with people i i think in this
entire scientific debate
we miss that picture of of the most
vulnerable community
uh which is already suffering and is
going to be devastating
well you mentioned the politics around
these negotiations and it's really
always felt like climate negotiations
have been
situated with an economics potentially
rather than a sense of moral collective
action
but it does seem that we are seeing this
growing awareness that a shift towards a
green economy actually makes more
financial sense
do you think that is might is that could
actually be what saves us the fact that
it would actually make people more money
to do that
see i i think that the point that you
made about green economy is probably the
only saving
silver lining that i see right now
in a way that renewables are becoming
real
uh electric vehicle is is going to
become uh you know much more cost
competitive in the next few years
uh we electric cooking
i mean to say fossil fuel that the trend
that we are following right now
on clean energy and clean technology
if we all work together collectively we
can make fossil fuel history
in next 10 to 15 years i'm literally
i i i'm saying this because in india for
example today
solar power is 40 cheaper than coal
power
a new solar plant will come at half the
cost of it
of a coal plant now these are these are
dramatic changes that has happened in
last five years uh since we have signed
the paris agreement
now countries need to recognize that
there is a stock of fossil fuel uh
infrastructure that we have in fact the
difficulty today is not
in building clean infrastructure but how
do we get rid of the old infrastructure
that we have
and therefore on one hand countries will
have to work on building new clean
infrastructure and green infrastructure
and which is as you rightly said is
profitable but we also have to start
talking about closing down old
infrastructure
and that's where the transition has to
be also just because
for example coal communities will suffer
and we don't want them to suffer as well
and we will have to think about how do
we transition coal plant and coal mining
areas
those are the things that the world will
also have to do so on one hand
we will have to do energy transition on
the other hand we will also have to work
on just transition
of communities which is going to suffer
of course chandra bhushan there from i
forest
reminding us of the need for urgent
action there thanks for being with us on
al jazeera chandra great to hear from
you
thank you very much